in spite of everything that we're doing
to slow down this virus it is still
outpacing the resources available to
treat it and that led President Trump to
extend the government social distancing
guidelines which are Jang reports from
the White House where the president
recently gave up on his target date to
lift restrictions we had a an aspiration
of Easter President Trump says he was
simply being hopeful when he repeatedly
touted reopening the country by Easter
last week but when you hear these kind
of numbers and you hear the potential
travesty that was an aspirational number
according to dr. Anthony Fauci 100 to
200,000 Americans could die from the
corona virus if we do not mitigate to
the extent that we're trying to do that
you could reach that number pouchy and
others had cautioned against lifting
restrictions too early the president
already has a new timeline we can expect
that by June 1st we will be well on our
way to recovery mr. Trump also
questioned why some hospitals are asking
for so many masks
how do you go from ten to twenty to
three hundred thousand ten to twenty
thousand masks to three hundred thousand
even though this is different
something's going on where the masculine
are they going out the back door
president Trump also claimed hospitals
may be hoarding ventilators but there is
no evidence for either claim the number
of confirmed cases nationally has risen
dramatically up almost five times from
what it was a week ago for CBS this
morning we judge the White House